[Music]
please get this man a gun we had a mini
matrix reunion with Laurence Fishburne
which I was excited to see yeah how did
you get him on board with this what was
that conversation like yeah I was at his
house and we were talking and catching
up and he was saying that he really
liked John wick and I said oh you do
well there so happens to be a role and
he was like send me the script and Chad
the director sent him the script he
loved the role he said yes and cut to
getting a chance to work with the
amazing awesome Laurence Fishburne I
heard that you were a fan of John wick
oh yeah yeah yeah what was your reaction
to finding out you're going to be in
John which I was excited I mean you know
what I I was hanging out with Keanu I
said dude the movies amazing and I would
love to be a part of the second one if
you do another one and he was like yeah
let me talk to the guys and they had
actually had something that they were
working on with me in mind and it just
it just really worked out
welcome to the real world and it's been
18 years since the matrix yeah how have
you grown how is Lawrence grown as an
actor oh gosh I don't know Lawrence it's
like he's in some other he's like a
universe where you don't even see it's
expanding but you know it's expanding
and you feel it right I mean he's
amazing for me just a lot of life
experience and stuff you see yourself
grow I've been really really fortunate
and blessed and you know most of my work
in recent years has been in the
television world and I've had a great
time with that whether it's CSIR
Hannibal and now blackish but yeah I
love what I do so you know I can only be
grateful and then from a friend's
perspective how have you seen Keanu grow
since the matrix he's taken charge of
his career and he's been instrumental in
putting together several of the movies
that have come out I remember him in my
kitchen telling me about the man of Tai
Chi like ten years ago and he you know
he stuck to it and worked hard and
raised the money and got it done so I've
been very very proud of him too